so we're here collected mania Gathol
it's great to see you here of course I'm
so sad so lost you and gave his friends
the season two you went from corty it's
a king do you think you had a very good
king if Renly had managed to get there
I think Remini would have made a
fantastic king I think yeah I'm I think
I'm sad for Westeros and in fact the
whole of George Martin's Empire that
he's gone because I think he's like the
only candidate that would make a really
decent king who's very astute actually
wasn't here in the kind of stuff he was
saying to Ned about that he should make
sure he gets Circe's children obviously
he bet he was wishing he'd taken his
advice now yeah I think he's he's grown
up in the court so he would have been he
was very good at the political side of
being a leader I think he perhaps had
something to prove on the battlefield it
was a incredible alliance and I I'm not
gonna be specific about this because it
was a couple years ago but I did know
all 20 it was either 20 to 26 somewhere
in that I knew all the families and who
supported him from from what I could
find out from George's where but also
the fanfiction you get a lot of
information from the wikis and things
like that it's really cool to do that
because you get your head in the world
of what the what the readers and the
watchers are imagining and you know it's
some of that knowledge faced with time
don't pretend to know now but but there
at the time when I was very very proud
of my sort of glorious Alliance of
families it's great I mean in Lawrence
as well he had such an influence on
Bradley didn't he I mean I suppose in
good ways and in bad ways because he in
a bad way that obviously he sadly ended
as he did because he went forward and
put himself forward as king and he
believed in him didn't he
yeah to be honest I think I think Renly
read the the affection and the power of
being in a lovely relationship gave her
any of the confidence and obviously some
specific dialogue you know indicates
that rhetoric influenced him but I think
Renly believed in himself that he could
be king once he had that confidence of a
from Loras but but I don't think you can
blame Loras for I think he was he was
very much a precocious young man as well
yeah talk about the fanfiction there of
it is there any other stuff that you
were reading online that particularly
stuck out the or did you read about your
reaction to your character and what was
happening to him as well
well when I say fanfiction I sort of
mean sort of more specifically George
Martin's fans helping with things like
collating historical data for Westeros
so like I read a timeline that I believe
was written by either a fan or maybe a
friend of George's I don't know but
someone had gone back and figured out
the timeline and put it up online for
everyone to see which was that really
useful resource to go okay so in that
year you know and then obviously I had
to sort of collect that with what David
and Dan and all writers were doing with
the history of the show because the cats
is different ages and you know copies be
specific about all these things but to
know that there was a there was a great
I believe I'm right in saying that there
was a great council about 50 years
before in the West or sister II I might
be wrong about that by 60 or 70 years
but but there was a previous precedent
of a council coming together to choose a
leader reading things like that about
the history of the world was really
really fascinating and helpful and this
is great you know other stories from the
sort of Martins world so I found that
useful and what was your reaction when
you got that script with your death
scene in and how did you go about
shooting it well it's quite an exciting
process really it was I think it's fair
to say that where the the death was
gonna appear in the series moved around
a teensy bit with the writers really
wanted to kind of get it right and I
think they did in making it as brutal as
possible as far as just cutting him off
dead and I started shooting it and we
just had a lot of fun with green screens
and silver balls and you know imagining
shadows behind you and David Pataki I
believe directed that bit he's just had
a lot of fun like with how the reaction
should go and had to put yourself in
that place of being as confident as you
could possibly be to having you know
through your torso in a split second so
you know we just played around and had
fun
what is Melisandre up to do you think I
think her aim is create a sort of a
franchise of wonderful restaurants
that's the best of George Martin's food
across the kingdoms and Essos I don't
know really what do I think she's up to
I think she's I think the character
Melisandre believes in her her faith
system in there and that's leading her
down a particular way and perhaps
irrespective of the real world around
her let's talk about one of the women
other women characters in the show as
well he's very taken of course is Renly
as many people were Brienne of Tarth now
what do you think she saw him Renly
she's a great actress as well plays or a
course Gwendolen yeah what Gwen
Gwendolyn was amazing for a couple of
reasons one she organized my birthday
party
while we were filming and I think it was
because she was getting into roles she
was like oh well my character loves you
so I'll just take you know I'll do these
lovely things for you which is really
sweet of essence no I think brie and
Brynn of Tarth just saw in Renly kind of
the side of him that was loving and
accepting and open and one of all the
good things that could be sort of you
know introduced to Westeros II socialite
life you know like being more accepting
and looks and and that he was a loving
individual and
perhaps pained by his inability to
express that love and if you know a Brit
Brian was on a similar journey and
perhaps likely have expressed her love
for perhaps Renly or whoever so yeah
it's a really interesting relationship
that I mean it's a shame gets cut off
quite so quickly but it makes sense and
then I'm really enjoying seeing her
journey Karen and I sort of feel like
her in her honourable ways she's
carrying on Wendy's journey a little bit
we live for as well she's great isn't
she
what was it like working with Finn as
well he plays Loras of course there's
great relationship between the two of
you on screen isn't that oh yeah I mean
which is amazing because he's awful he's
a horrible human being and I think it's
probably quite well it mean a thing got
on really well and yeah I mean we just
had a whale of a time doing it and I
know especially the first season we
really took our what we were doing very
seriously is to get it right and then we
could just enjoy it and I think the
second season was really fun and and to
have Natalie and Gwen turn up be part of
our little run these gangs oh you know
even you know Loras is getting whatever
bit Wendy's going it was really fun and
and and I know that they liked having a
whale of a time on set now and I kind of
miss hanging out with him a little bit
when they're working but what do you see
when you want you what do you feel when
you look at the show now and you see
what Loras is going through
so many emotions deep betrayal by
Marjorie that's the one that's that
really I can't I can't really watch it a
little bit but I and I haven't watched
all of the available series three I
think I was about halfway and I it's
just tricky you know you sort of yeah I
find it really hot I had to lie there
when in this scene where you see my
corpse and they're like talking over me
and my even then Marjorie was planning
to you and I are still great no I mean
they're fantastic actors I love the
stories and I get into the Mo's any feel
would say hey dude I'm still here yeah
yeah I think there was a moment when I
got sent a photo from someone of like a
new character that maybe Lois was having
a relationship with on set in the
stories and I was a bit like that's a
low blow I mean that you know talking
about the relationships they have
obviously a lot of people under on the
show you have a kind of intimate scenes
and I know there's a big crew there so
was it like kind of psyching yourself up
for that sort of stuff and knowing
there's so many kind of people around
you well then I mean they do it's right
to say that on any film said there's a
lot of people involved they make it easy
on you they do I refer to as close sets
which are less people it's to cry few
people around
and I have so with Natalie the scene
shot with NASA dormer who just on her I
think was on her first day we had to do
quite an intimate scene it should just
I learned a lot from her she's
incredibly professional she's done a lot
of screen working and then had to do
some quite intimate scenes and things
like that and to see how professionally
she dealt with it was like a real sort
of lesson from you know I thought she
was fantastic to sort of learn from and
I I do think for women maybe it comes up
more often or I don't know but it's
she's basically she's a real pro at
dealing with all that and then but the
guys on set are really professional
to be honest I quite like that you can
sort of pop out the back and maybe have
a joke with something about it office
sort of release the tension a bit but
yeah you just sort of get on with it and
people are very respectful of I mean you
know if you think about everyone's
trying to tell the same story so people
are aware of what's being told at any
given time whether that be a child in
the scene or a very violent scene or you
know if it's an intimate scene so you
know it's so really Pro crew out there
and it makes it really easy what have
been your favorite moments for the show
so far as a viewer or as a participant
take both you know it's about I think as
a viewer I still that what actually the
stimulus I thought that this a lot but
the very very very opening just blew me
away because I knew what to expect in a
way and but I just thought they
absolutely nailed it to a war I couldn't
imagine a better opening to TV serious
whatever but also is so cliche but then
the way they captured Ned's passing was
so perfectly pitched between
just being brutally truthful but also
some sort of suspense but just knowing
that no you're gonna see his head on a
spike a minute I mean I did still gets
me they look hot I thought she was
incredible a scene and they captured it
short performance incredibly well and
mazes and everybody else in that scene
so that was as a viewer though it's sort
of like they do stand out I mean but
I've got so many favorite moments no
does heiresses death is awesome I've
seen gold pulled over Harry's head can
never be a bad thing he's a good mate
and and he was so excited about shooting
and I was so excited seeing and again he
nails that scene but the moments before
his death you just used sort of almost
going with him and that's great you know
what some loads of moments as a
participant I think getting to work with
actually all of like Michelle Gwen
Natalie and Finn in that last season was
a real treat and Steven and Liam and
Carissa say no he's an amazing cast yet
you know and that's having worked with
all those other factors everyone sees
one so as an acted they were loads of
favorite moments I really enjoyed today
really the scene on on horseback with
Stephen was really fun because I've
never shot a scene on horseback nor on a
cliff in the wind and finally you got a
message to the fans out there who
watching this video and what did it mean
for you to be part of Game of Thrones
yeah I mean I guess it was just a huge
privilege and one I'm extraordinary
thankful to have had the opportunity to
have and I hope everyone keeps enjoying
it and keep supporting the guys and what
they're doing especially David down in
the show runners and the writers and
trying to capture George's work and best
way they can and keep enjoying it it
didn't love you to speak to you thank
you - thank you
you